i'm i i want to convey
probably some things about sentiments
and also
admiration um i had an
arc that started 46 years ago
and nothing existed and over those 46
years
i now look at the company
and i say what a great
company with great people
all that you're hearing and
with what a great culture
and i want to just in again one sentence
say what that culture is which is
an idea meritocracy
in which the goals are meaningful work
and meaningful relationships
through radical truthfulness and radical
transparency
and so emotionally
all along the way every one of those
things
happened there were births there were
deaths
there were up
ups and downs um
there were all of those things um it
bring life springs you all of those
things
there were there were battles there were
pains um you know the the journey
um you know some of it um
there was a plan when i originally
thought i would transition
i said um i think this will probably
take about
two years but since i never did it
before and it's supposed to be difficult
um i'm going to allow up to 10 years
okay well it was 10 years
and it and it had some brutal and
difficult
moments and at the same time
we are here together that bob
and greg and dave
and us are here together and so
as i look back on that journey
bridgewater's journey my personal
journey
over 46 years you know that's
longer than the average age of the
people here
i wish i could capture that well for you
and also
show you the essence of it i hope you
see the essence
i think many of you do but as you
if you see the innocence then you
understand
why you can go through these ups and
downs
together effectively
it's an amazing thing 46 years
and then to look back and then also to
be able to sit
here and as i say you know
the real accomplishment is when at 71
i can sit back and watch beauty happen
so for me when i look forward i look
forward to doing it in a way that
uh serves um
that you know as as a mentor a coach
as somebody who helps um
and but there's a saying um at
this stage in life uh joseph campbell
described it as being free to live and
free to die
and to be able to pass that along and so
this is this is immensely satisfying for
me
i think you understand the arc i think
you understand what's essential
but it can go on it's better than ever
and it can go on great without me and
i'm so grateful
to the people i'm grateful to dave he's
a great leader
i'm grateful to bob greg and
i can go on and on so anyway this is
such a beautiful moment and i'm very
grateful thank you